see why we got a fight going on at the
uh bar
or the DJ deck is it's about four or
five males fighting
in the middle of all this uh Juniper
yeah for all the crowded people are
standing
therefore I got one guys pretty bloodied
up
I don't know how much effect there's
still two of them still trying to go at
each other
you're gonna need rescue
yeah one guy on the deck looks like he's
unconscious completely deadly from the
face
[Applause]
yeah he's unconscious large guy on the
uh DJ deck
a lot of blood coming from the head pace
have a seat brother have a seat
let's have a seat
let's have a seat man all right have a
seat there you go
pull it all the way out there you go
there we go all right thanks brother
[Applause]
yeah they're gonna spin it thank you
appreciate it
on everyone
right now